all right this is a fun episode Sam
started doing Legos and that sent us
down this Rabbit Hole where he
discovered two businesses that I never
heard of I guarantee you never heard of
it they're awesome businesses in the
Lego niche of all things and then we
brainstormed other things that people
could do around these passionate Niche
audiences that most people Overlook love
it this is MFM classic MFM special if
you like this podcast you're gonna love
this one uh and I also had like an
epiphany about 45 minutes in that kind
of changed the way I think about this
podcast so that's that's what I got out
of this episode Sam what did you get so
while searching this stuff there is a
ton of twists and turns to the story the
background story of how these companies
started I want you guys to listen to
them it doesn't happen it's the second
story involving Lego you'll know exactly
what I'm talking about when we get there
it's about two-thirds of the way into
the episode I got emotional researching
this and I actually want you guys to
like listen to the topics and the
companies that we brought up I want you
to go to their websites and see what I'm
talking about you'll know exactly what
I'm talking about when you get to the
the part of the episode and let us know
in the YouTube comments if this actually
got to you like it got to me I dug it it
was tons of like weird parts of the
stories that I did not expect to happen
anyway check it out and let us know in
the YouTube comments if you actually dug
this because I think you will and which
parts of the stories you like
[Music]
best what is up Sean here with Sam your
boys who are stuck at
399,000 YouTube
subscribers they said we'd never get to
400 in fact there's still saying we'd
never get to 400 s did you see this
tweet that went viral that goes all my
haters said I wouldn't make it I didn't
make it they were right honestly good
call by the
haters it's like a legendary
tweet I love that stuff um yeah we're at
399 the I I read every YouTube comment
do you read and reply bro not to
everyone but I I reply like it's like a
I'm in line at a coffee shop I'll just
go through and go through a whole
episode and try to reply as many as I
can yeah so uh if you're listening and
you're not on YouTube do do your boys a
favor and just click subscribe it means
a lot to us it costs you nothing and uh
we've got a good episode today we have
we last time we talked we both had the
same topic written down and we did it
again it happened again this time uh
before we get into the episode I got to
tell you something how big is your house
square
footage uh 5600 I'm in a house right now
I'm visiting family so I rented an air
B&B for 2 weeks my home my normal home
in Austin is uh just a little over 2,000
s ft it's not big it's nice but it's not
big I'm currently renting a 7500 foot
house I am losing so much stuff this is
such a big house I think that even 55
would be too big for me do you like
having a big house like that yeah it's
great what's not to love I'll tell you
one the utility bill here if I had to
guess it's like 2,000 a month what's
your utility bill well you're in
California so you don't really use too
much I don't check it uh I don't I don't
look uh everything's on autopay and I
don't even want to look I it's probably
like ,200 $1,500 I guess wow okay so
that's expensive but whatever uh but the
other thing things break all the time
like there's seven bathrooms here and
like one of the the guy has like a
Jacuzzi thing in one of his bathrooms
it's not working I don't you going and
using all seven bathrooms that's you you
don't use half the [__] the [__] that's
the trick that's how it breaks that's
how breaks you just don't use it and so
anyway I I wanted to buy a big home
eventually and I'm happy I'm testing
this out it's such a big house I
understand the downsides to it of just
like fixing things it's a pain in the
butt well here's my here's my my rule
number of humans plus two that's how
many beds that's how many bedrooms I
want in my house number of humans plus
two bedrooms and one of those bedrooms
turns into man cave like where I have
the studio here right now this is one of
the bedrooms we just converted and the
other one's a guest room uh now my kids
are small right now so they're like all
sleeping in the same bed and stuff like
that it doesn't really help but as they
get older that rule is going to come
into effect yeah and I think maybe my
needs will change but I just wanted to
test out a big house I'm shocked by how
much I dislike it so
farle things most people don't do this
at all and you do it a lot which is
where do I want to live how do I want to
live do I want to live in a city do I
want to live in the suburbs do I want to
live in a big house small house near
water you know what matters to me uh
because I think a lot of people have
these
predefined ideas that are completely
based on nothing no evidence and uh I
really take a lot of inspiration from
the way you test out Lifestyles you
prototype like how you want to live and
uh more people should do that for sure I
I do it all the time and the reason I do
it is because if you think about it so
renting a really fancy Airbnb for a week
it could be expensive let's just say
it's $1,000 a night or more so let's
just say let's round up and say it's 10
grand for a week that's expensive but
you know what's more expensive buying a
home that you only see for 24 hours and
or through a 1 hour tour and being like
cool this is my place now for the next
10 or 20 years that's way more expensive
Andrew honestly you start to lose a
little trust in yourself it's like Oh I
thought this would make me happy it
turns out I didn't even like this right
uh I'm not listening to that guy anymore
and by the way you don't have to be rich
to do this lifestyle testing like I was
doing this when I had you know no money
because well I didn't have it it's all
relative to where you're at right so
it's where do I want to live I would
move to like I would do a road trip and
we would drive to another place live on
a friend's couch but we would live there
for two weeks and just kind of see okay
what's it like in this place like
where're I tried in Chicago then I tried
in Colorado and then you know I just
tested out different places in order to
see where do I want to be and um I think
that's a very smart way to to go about
things you want to talk about Legos my
man let's talk about Legos can I
introduce this category with which is
the following you text me and you go
dude I'm playing a ton of Legos what
it's like yeah every night I'm playing
Legos do you do this and I was like no I
don't do this but I know a bunch of
other people that doing it caught my
attention because I'm not sure if you
know this but this is kind of becoming
this like uh trendy thing so there's a
bunch of like NBA players that kind of
came out of the closet saying yeah this
is what I do at night the closet yeah
know the reputation for NBA players
we're all out at the strip club after
games and whatever and there's like this
guy Miles Turner he's like I'm building
like replica Star Wars like you know
stars with with my Legos at night four
or five hours a night and I got kind of
interested so I looked at it by the way
in college I lived with the basketball
team in college they were the biggest
nerds of all the
athletes like they they didn't go out
given them wedgies six seven wedgies
well like like a Friday night was
playing video games like it it was like
they were the least party animal of all
the athletes all right everyone a quick
break to tell you about HubSpot and this
one's easy because I'm going to show you
an example of how I'm doing this at my
company when I say I I mean not my team
I mean I'm the one who actually made
this so I've got this company called
Hampton you can check it out join
hampton.com it's a community for
Founders and one of the ways that we've
grown is we've created these surveys
where we'll ask our members certain
questions that a lot of people a lot of
times people are afraid to ask so things
like what their net worth is how their
assets are allocated all these like
interesting questions and then we'll put
it in a survey and I went and made a
landing page so you can check it out at
join hampton.com wealth you can actually
see the landing page that I made and the
hard part with this is with Hampton we
are appealing to a sort of a a
higher-end customer sort of like like a
Louis Vuitton or Ferrari so I needed the
landing page to look a very particular
way HubSpot has templates that's what we
use we just change the colors a little
bit to match our brand very easy they
have this drag and drop version of their
Landing Page Builder and it's super
simple I'm not Technical and I'm the one
who actually made it and once it's made
I then shared it on social media and we
had thousands of people see it and
thousands of people who gave us their
information and I can then see over the
next handful of weeks
this is how much revenue came in from
this wealth survey that I did this is
where the revenue came from so it came
from Twitter it came from LinkedIn
whatever it came from I can actually go
and look at it and I can say oh well
that worked that didn't work do more of
that do less of that and if you're
interested in making landing pages like
this I highly suggest it look I'm
actually doing it but you can check it
out go to the link in the description of
YouTube and get started all right now
back to MFM so do you know what this
category is
called is it called the is it the
acronym that starts in the a no no no
they call them they call people like you
Cults the toy industry they call you
guys Cults and cads or Elder tainment is
the name of this group of people that
are adults buying kids toys and that
sounds like a pretty fringe thing but it
actually makes up 25% of all toy sales
so billions and billions of dollars one
one one out of every four people that go
by you know let's say a set of Legos is
going to be an you know older teenager
or adult
you know what they call for Legos for
specifically for Legos it's called the I
don't it's one of those words that I've
see but I don't know if you're supposed
to how you're supposed to say it but
afol adult fan of Legos that's you're
self-identified as an
AF actual [__] old Lego
maker so so this uh this category uh
like it makes up all the growth in the
toy industry so toy industry if you look
at how fast this growing 60% of all the
growth is just coming from this one
segment so it's like this like kind of
this segment that's growing really fast
at first I didn't understand it but then
they did some surveys right because all
the toy companies were like what's going
on here we this is not what we planned
for so several years ago they
commissioned a bunch of studies and they
they went and asked why are you doing
this and I'm curious if you're going to
say the same thing because 90% of the
adults all said the same three reasons
that they do it what are your reason Sam
bonding with my family well in my family
my wife um no no screens and we can just
sit at the table and do it together
while we're just talking and maybe there
will be TV on in the back background but
it's basically bonding without screens
sitting at the table and it reminds me
of my
childhood that's exactly right the uh
The three-word Nostalgia which you just
said um anti- loneliness so bonding with
with whoever you're you're doing it with
and detoxing from from phone as well as
kind of like an anti-anxiety angle to it
like is a relaxing a relaxing activity
because I'm following Direction
I'm just following the directions I'm
not making any decisions I'm doing what
I'm told that's interesting oh okay I
thought it was kind of the hands part of
it but you're saying as an adult I'm
constantly having to make decisions and
think and it's so nice to not make
decisions and just be told put this blue
thing over here yeah it's like a it's
like a a PG rated dominatrix you know
like instead of spitting in my mouth
it's telling me to like connect the
these two
pieces yeah some people you're into that
stuff all right to each his
own and so this is fascinating to me so
I want you to tell me I have some more
ideas
around like more ex I have a bunch of
examples around this trend and some
ideas of what I think people could do
but before we do that I just want to
know what are you what are you actually
doing so you're buying Lego kits like
which ones and what do you what do you
do so Lego is this huge company so I
think they do about $10 billion doll a
year in sales uh it was started in like
the 20s by just an engineer
and now they have got they've got movies
characters it's like a it's like a
Marvel almost it's like a a whole
franchise I particularly like the line
called Technics and Technics is cool
because it's basically you'll build cars
or tractors or uh a bridge and there's
gears within the machine and so I'm
learning how like you know like in the
snow when um old cars when you spin your
tires only one tire would spin sometime
that's because of a rear uh differential
that's like a mechanical piece and so
I'm like building that and I'm
understanding how transmission works I'm
building I built a Land Rover that has
six a six-speed transmission and I see
how how gears work and so it's really
fascinating to me to see these moving
parts so I build Technics I've probably
spent $1,500 on them so far each one is
between 150 and 350 and I buy only the
Technics one that that's my thing and
you're you finish them in one sitting or
these are like multi-week no no I one a
week so but it'll take I'll sit for 2
hours and if my wife's not with me I'll
listen to a podcast or something and
I'll just sit there for 2 hours
assembling it from like 9 to 11 just you
and the voice of Scott Galloway yeah I'm
just like I'm listening to like some War
story so it's like just like me and me
and Bonito melini as I build this Land
Rover like this like 6 inch tractor
yeah I love by the way how you're like
yeah I built a six you know a six-speed
transmission
it's like no no no you didn't you really
didn't I feel like you got a lot of
confidence from this that like I could
came down to it I now could and uh I
don't think you could man so all right
so you're doing this is this a fat or
you think this is like a lifelong hobby
for you what do you what are you
thinking lifelong I could see it being
lifelong wow yeah what you do with them
when you're done you finished the the
six-speed tractor whatever what are you
going to do with this so one of the
companies that I'm going to bring up but
basically you tell this company that
I'll I'll break down and explain what
sets you have and you destroy them and
you rebuild them using different plans
and so you can make alternative items
out of them and so that's what I intend
to do ah okay all right they're not
gonna sit on a shelf I'm not going to be
like the 40 Old Virgin and have like
dolls and packages still unused no I it
it really is a enjoy the journey type of
thing so once I'm done with it I'm like
I don't care about it okay good um so I
wanted to bring up a couple couple other
examples cuz I I saw this and I was like
H that's weird that's interesting about
Legos and I was like no there's
something to this like cult Behavior
right where adults buying and doing kid
things that is you know antiphone anti
loneliness and uh and nostalgic and um
I'm going to give you some examples of
of trends that are like this so the
first is calm um we're both friends with
the the founders of Comm Alex and
Michael and I don't know if you remember
this but back in the day
Comm was really struggling today Comm is
like kind of very popular it's a
multi-billion dollar company but back
when we were living in San Francisco and
hang out with Alex uh Comm was like
small it was a slow grower it was not
sexy nobody wanted to it was kind of a
joke like a meditation app are you
kidding me and Alex is very jokey and
the other things he built like Million
Dollar Homepage were all jokes so it's
kind of like oh cool and the other guy
built like a stuffed animal business
before that yeah so they were definitely
like non-serious serious entrepreneurs
um they but I remember one time talking
to Michael so Michael came to visit from
London and he's like I was like so what
do you do with comp because you're not
even here full-time Alex is sitting in
his apartment grinding away at this
thing that's not really going too fast
growing too fast what are you doing and
he's like oh I'm work I work on new
products and I'm like dude this is not
like uh you know he looks at Richard
Branson I was like this is not Virgin
Atlantic what new products he's like no
no I got a great one he goes uh I want
to do um bedtime story for
adults and I was like what he's like no
no no I was like that's okay whatever
marketing stunt I guess he's like no no
I think this is going to be a thing he
goes keep people are going to like he's
like a lot of adults they listen to
things before they sleep to help them
relax and help them actually like fall
asleep but they're not done very well do
you uh yeah I do sometimes I have like I
have like a version of white noise that
I sometimes listen to or I'll just
listen to podcast and fall asleep which
is not the same thing but uh there's
like a relax people who want a Rel a
relaxation thing in fact I think one of
the top podcasts in the world is just
like 18 hours of sleep sounds and it's
like I listen to a I listen to Family
Guy when I go to bed and I just hear
like Peter like I just hear that while
I'm going to sleep yeah to sleep exactly
and so he's like I'm gonna do the thing
they ended up being sleep stories and
sleep stories were one of the things
that really let C take off it like
exploded after sleep stories in fact I
would say that c is it's less about
meditation it is more about the state of
being commmon and really the number one
product is the Sleep stories and they
got Matthew mccon to narrate this like
bedtime story and he was hosting I don't
know if you remember this in San
Francisco he would before to prototype
this he was hosting parties in San
Francisco where you would go to This
Woman's house and you would lay down on
her carpet and you would have like a
pillow and they would like set the mood
and then she would just talk and put you
to sleep and then everybody would go to
sleep and um it was the most San
Francisco thing ever and these are that
was like a party it was like it was like
a networking event it was like it was
amazing and so but you think cm is going
to have toy or you're saying the the toy
is no I'm saying this is part of the
same thing like adults using adults
using kid product basically so bedtime
stories for adults that's another
version of yeah you know adults using
Legos my family member I have family
members I won't even say who they are
they might be embarrassed who go to
sleep to calm bedtime stories it what's
embarrassing about that that's awesome I
don't know I don't know you never know
I'm not going to out
someone
so there's also like Moon Pals and
squishmallows have you seen these yeah I
know Moon pal they like basically giant
stuffed animals but they're geared more
towards adults than they are for kids
and you see like you know 24 year-old
girls in the Bronx who like have like a
you know like a moon pal that they carry
around little like safety blanket Funko
Pop is that is that what it's called
what's the Funko Funko is a publicly
traded company you know that no they
they're they're like a $400 million uh
market cap company during the during
covid when everybody was stuck at home
and people started just spending money
collecting or buying crypto or doing
whatever Funko was like over a billion
dollar because they were selling so many
of these figurine doll things figurine
like dolls that's all it is yeah it's
just like a little a little toy um toy
figure action figure no action I guess
just just toy figurine that U has an
oversized head and
we that's funny uh we had talked about
mini Brands as well like the company
mini brands that makes Mini
I don't even like Coke cans uh those are
insane too another one have you ever
been to Builder
bear dude they they kill it yeah I've
taken a nephew there so build-a bear is
like this thing in the mall where you go
build a teddy bear it's usually like you
know was four kids you know that 40% of
their revenue now comes from adults
that's insane that's insane absolutely
and they call it Build-A-Bear after dark
they basically like open up at late
hours and let adults come in and
basically like you know do it as a date
night Act ity and stuff like that it's
crazy um there's more American do uh you
know I don't know if you you had a
sister so you would know American do but
I bet Ari knows American do or had an
American do American dos still crush it
uh you know what American do is no is
that not Barbie that's something else
it's different it's a doll that's maybe
three foot tall it back then they would
cost $150 so it was a big deal and there
it was sort of like gi. Joe but for
girls and there was like an American
doll student and so it looked like a
little girl who was going to Harvard or
American Doll astronaut or something
like that it was like themed but they
were supposed to be more high-end than a
Barbie and more collectible I think
American doll only fans Creator oh they
have like new new genres that's great so
they
um
so uh there's there's just like like
even Barbie by the way do you know bar
you know how the Barbie movie came about
because like the Barbie movie is not not
geared towards kids right like if you've
seen it it's it's not a it's not a
kids's movie really it's an adult it's
like geared towards adults and that this
is the reason why they actually bar
Barbie the company actually created an
internal movie production company to
create this movie geared towards adults
to help sell more dolls into this Kult
uh like uh segment and so there's a
marketing stunt for that which is kind
of crazy when you think about it I
didn't realize that about the Barbie
movie um but like there's also tabletop
gaming so you know those guys from
churnin they've made like big bets on
tabletop gaming which is basically board
games that adults play they have like
exploding kittens and they have some
other ones but that's another genre even
McDonald's came out with an adult happy
meal I don't know if you saw this last
year just a hilarious like they made a
bigger box with full-size fries and an
adult toy and they did this last year
and it was like this viral marketing
stunt that went crazy because everyone's
like oh dude I want to go get one and it
like went viral on Tik Tok and stuff
like that brands are really capitalizing
on this so I have a few ideas I want to
pitch pitch you I want you to tell me
you could just give me a uh genius or
idiot on these this is sort of like a
mini drunk ideas episode for all right
all right first
one you know how you've seen the stats
how Millennials are just like not
getting married and not having babies
like it's like a lower rate than ever
before yeah tamagachi for babies so
basically you give you give that
28-year-old who's single and whatever
you give a tamagachi that's a baby that
they got to keep they got to raise and
they got to take care of like tamagachi
I think we're pets screw it we're just
doing an actual human baby you got to
take care of this thing and it literally
is the same level of uh like same same
like hourly needs as a baby and let's
see what you got so Tom I got you for
babies that's my first one so the
problem with these ideas is if you would
have told me about the things that are
successful now that they like this is
this is going to work I would have said
those are all horrible ideas
so this is like a really challenging
category that's why I prepped You by
telling you all the ones that worked
before I told you my bad ideas just to
kind of like frame you like Prime you
for like hey I don't know man anything's
possible so do I think T yes I think I
think there there'd be legs for
tamagachi what what happened to the
company ah dude I have no idea what's
tamagachi it's a it's a Japanese
business yeah it's a it's based in Japan
yeah I i' believe that a tamagi for
babies it's a standalone device that's
going to replicate having a baby all
right that's number one
number two did you ever use
connects yeah I love connects you ever
build a big ferris wheel no because
connects were hard and I had a cousin I
have a cousin who's the same age as me
looks like me last name Puri and this
guy's way smarter than me and I I'm
pretty sure the reason he's way smarter
than me is that his dad bought him
connects when he was a little kid and he
was just making connects all day every
day after school I was playing Dreamcast
and he was building connects guess what
he does now I have a podcast he builds
like self-driving cars this guy is a
genius so like I'm pretty sure conect is
the uh you know the number one
contributing factor to this guy being a
genius dude listen to this connects was
sold in 2018 for only 2 $21 million I
know I know crazy what I what happened
how is Lego like a $50 billion company
and connects sold for $21 million like
what happened here and when you were
describing the Lego Technics it's very
similar so connects the difference was
that it was more kind of like a stem kid
thing where it's like sciencey and mathy
where it's like you you know you have
these like little like rotating wheels
and mo it's almost like a motor that
you're creating it's like a high
functioning version of Legos that's how
I describe you by the way you're you're
you're a high functioning version of a
Lego that basically
you I take that as a compliment so I
think conect should just like somebody
should just reboot
conects targeted at as for adults that
want to do Legos basically uh the guys
like you literally connects for S par
that's my next idea go ahead yeah I'm in
that's a that's a no-brainer I'm in so
conect was acquired in
2019 and they're basically not that
existent anymore because of because of a
bunch of tariffs uh something like where
they couldn't import them but uh yeah
I'm me I think I think they sold a bunch
through like Toys R R Us and then Toys R
R Us went bankrupt and I think they lost
a bunch of Revenue there so I think just
hey little bad luck you know unfortunate
bounce of the ball there and I feel like
connect still is a good opportunity all
right here here's my next one all right
what else easier Rubik's
Cube can you do a Rubik's Cube no I
can't I cannot can you you kind of wish
you could yeah yeah I mean what we used
to do is just take the stickers
off you take the stickers off and and
then you put them all back in the right
place and you can brag that you did it
oh okay gotcha you can Al just buy it
new and it's done so um what's the
easiest party trick you could do like I
can juggle can you do anything like that
yeah um if I smoke a cigarette I could
blow smoke out my
ear really I swear to God yeah I've had
all these your ear I've had all these
surgeries in my ear and so like some
pipes got rerouted and I used to be able
to blow smoke out my
ear dude how do we not start every
podcast with that come
on sandbagging us we would be at 400,000
subscribers but solving a Rubik's Cube
is a close second though all right
easier Rubik's Cube so I think Rubik's
Cube fun little idea it's kind of like a
fidget spinner anyways the way that the
Rubik's Cube feels however too hard way
too hard and we get it if you could do a
Rubik's Cube that's fantastic that's
chess where's Checkers I need a Checkers
of Rubik's cubes and so um here's what
I'm thinking letters on the outside and
it's kind of like wle wle is a very fun
game simple game you play every day you
could build a daily habit I think
somebody needs to take the concept of
wle but put it in the form factor of a
Rubik's Cube where every day you get a
notification on your phone or there's a
website that posts the starting letter
combination and then you got to rotate
it to make the word and it should take
like five minutes it's like you know do
you play the New York Times mini
crossword no do you every day this
thing's amazing it's such a fun it's 60
it's a literally like a 60-second break
it's a game it's a cross word crosswords
are kind of fun but a real cross cross
is pretty hard and timec consuming and
the when New York Times made this mini
it that thing dri like millions of
dollars like it's like I don't know 10%
of New York times's Revenue comes from
this little game app and it's mostly the
New York Times mini crossword this thing
is an absolute hit product all right I
have two more candle pouring kits so
another thing that is highly tactile
highly satisfying leaves you with a
result a candle um candle pouring is
something I see a lot on Tik Tok I don't
know exactly how it goes or how it works
but I'm pretty sure this could be
another like adult crap arts and crafts
relaxation thing that that is accessible
to many and results in you actually
having something that's not just clutter
and junk in your house because you could
just light the candle use it melt it
down and then you're done so I think a
candle pouring kit uh company could do
pretty well dude I'm in on that one
because you'd want to buy one you you'd
want to continually buy them if you got
into it right um yeah and candles make a
ton of money like go look at the candle
mlms uh if you want to know what
products work go look at what mlms work
and work backwards from there so there
are several multi-level marketing
schemes that are based around candles
which tells me there's a giant market
for candles tell me one more and then I
want to blow your mind with the Lego
Story okay um I'm now seeing what I
wrote here and I have no idea what this
means so I'm G to just take this as a uh
as a blank canvas for myself relaxation
puddle I don't know what I meant when I
wrote this this is late last night um I
think what I oh I think what this is is
like my kids uh one of the things you do
with kids is you give them something
called like sensory play so you buy this
like box and you put in like Orbeez or
you put in these like gel Circle things
you put your hand in it's kind of this
cool sensation it's like it's like very
cold you they're like these like balls
that you can kind of like you know um
you can touch and feel but they're not
like uh it's like slime you know slime's
really popular for kids there's like all
these things that are very tactile
Play-Doh and so you I think what I was
thinking here is it's very relaxing
saying if you put your hands in this
thing what if you could put your whole
body in this thing I think is what I was
thinking it's more like those uh those
uh sensory deprivation tanks that people
like to do in San Francisco uh and maybe
other places as well I'm not sure but
something you could just go lay in and
it's like a super nap is really where my
head was going I'm trying to yes and you
but it's really hard when the premise is
a relaxation
puddle dude the word puddle is so
underrated actually sounds great uh has
all kinds of jokes and commentation very
memeable word and I think that's what
you want with any of these you want the
idea to be so stupid that you get memed
into popularity you understand what I'm
saying here yeah here what you're gonna
do you're gonna do it it's gonna sound
ridiculous and 95% of America wants to
make fun of you but then that those
articles go out those memes go out and
then 5% of people are like I don't know
I'd try it right like you remember when
that thing happened that like guys were
lay on their back and they were like
suntanning their butthole and they're
like yeah that's the new thing I don't
even think that was a thing but I think
there was someone behind that that was
like you know what we'll get written up
everywhere automatically overnight if I
say that this is a thing I've got this
friend Chris who would send me so many
photos of you just see his legs like as
if he's not very clothed with his legs
in the air and he's like just say his
last name he deserves it for doing that
just being
healthy uh like Crocs are like this
right they're intentionally ugly they're
intentionally so ugly you have to talk
about them and the design like stands
out in a not so good way but the result
of it is that uh you know gets talked
about yeah like you just got to figure
out what the [__] a relaxation puddle is
first you're just starting with the word
let me tell you two crazy stories the
second one is in particularly crazy and
I think you're actually going to dig it
because it it's going to revolve around
your world so I'm a Lego fan I like
doing Legos now it's my new thing
there's this website called rebrickable
so rebrickable is this amazing website
it was clearly started by an engineer I
think his name is I actually don't know
what the guy's name is who started it
Nathan I think his name is Nathan so
Nathan was uh uh just an engineer at
some company normal job in Australia he
started this website that he it's
actually quite complicated and what you
do there there's tens of thousands of
Lego kits you know and it's been around
for a 100 years so there's probably
hundreds of thousands of different types
of Lego kits kits you tell it what type
of Lego sets you have and then other
designers so people who are Lego fans
have created directions on how to build
their own Creations it's called anoc My
Own creation and it's a whole community
of people who build moc's and he has
roughly 30,000 people who have uploaded
a variety of moc's that you can buy from
$10 probably all the way up to
$100 and what's interesting about this
guy there's so many crazy business
implications here but what's interesting
about this guy is a he's an engineer and
the the the people who listen to this
podcast there's a bunch of Engineers out
there there's a huge overlap of Ben
diagram of Lego enthusiasts and this guy
adds a third circle to that Ben diagram
of business people and so basically it
had he reveals all of his stats online
and you could go to his blog and you
could see it he started this company I
think in 2010 and it was just a project
I looked at his LinkedIn he worked as a
full-time per uh had a full-time job
since 20 uh until 2020 and he WR reveals
every year how much page views that the
website has had how many registered
users it's had how many people are
selling products on there so it's
basically a Marketplace and so in 2023
he had 11 million users create an
account on his website which is wow
which is huge and so if you account for
let's say 3% of people buy something
that's 330,000 people or sales who
bought an m so someone's directions on
building something say the average sale
is about 15 bucks that's about $5
million in Revenue that is uh collected
and of course he gives a lot to most of
it to the designer but there's people
who have whole like stores on the
website and it's really fascinating and
his page views last year 2023 were
around 160 million page views and if you
look at his website he blogs every year
and he says what his stats are how many
page viws he's had he has and it's a
very interesting blog to read because a
he's being transparent about the
business and B you could see how to
build like a rabid community so on his
blog and it's clearly a self-built Blog
he's not even using Wordpress he built
everything from scratch you'll see the
comments saying I love this community
I'm So Into uh rebrickable like Nathan
you're the man like people are are rabid
about this uh Niche it's incredibly
fascinating and this type of guy I'm
just going to stereotype him he's not a
business savvy person or at least he
doesn't want to be like he's not out
there trying to milk this dry and make
as much money as possible but this type
of business that he has once you get
users to a passionate following like
this to your website you can sell them
anything and so what Andrew Wilkinson
calls us is an airport business so once
you're there well while you're here we
could sell you this we could sell you
that it's people are here to learn and
they're ready to buy and the reason why
this is fascinating is because with
Legos you know they cost hundreds of
dollar sometimes and you want to buy a
new one every month every couple months
and so the market is actually quite big
to build a big business this is like a a
type of company that if you wanted to be
a PE guy which I don't think you should
because this is like a work of art to me
but if you wanted to be a PE guy and buy
a business that you could milk for tons
of profit and you don't actually have to
do that much Innovation this is one of
those
websites dude what a great find this is
such a cool cool business yeah 10
million users and by the way look at
this I looked I went to top designers we
got to put this on the screen so that
our
399,000 YouTube subscribers can see this
the Chinese restaurant this thing is
insane this is insane who who made this
up this is so crazy this this is insane
and the technology to build this stuff
is amazing because a you could just buy
anoc from someone and they'll tell you
what parts or kits that you need and
they they'll sell them or you could
there's this like crazy algorithm that
they have where you upload hundreds of
different kits that you have and then
you click like submit and then you see
like a wheels turning and it takes like
60 seconds as if it's like doing heavy
like calculations and then it'll give
you a huge list of hundreds or thousands
of different's that others have uploaded
that you can create with the parts that
you have and it'll say you have 100% of
the parts need for this or you have 50%
of the parts here's the other 50% that
you have you can buy them here it's
really fascinating and it's quite
complicated I would imagine to build
that you found like dork Mecca this is
great it's the best not only adults
doing Legos adults doing Legos who need
custom customade Lego like designs this
is insane uh yeah this is cool by the
way this Chinese
restaurant three thou 2,000 pieces 10
bucks for the for theoc what a steal
it's amazing and they they there's
people I like there's people in the
forums saying that they're close to
making a full-time living selling their
moc's and so when you have a rabid base
like this it's crazy fascinating to see
what types of businesses you can build
now this particular model is very unique
to Lego but you could look at what the
sneaker heads have done with shoes you
know like that was like considered silly
a few years ago there was a small group
of people and they created marketplaces
for it but this is a perfect example of
how this is executed well of these Niche
followings and going all in on them and
building them for the community and
what's interesting is check this out so
in year one he had uh a million people
come to the website so in year one so um
so that's 80,000 people a month that's
pretty good but it's it's not crazy
that's pretty good his paid yous were 11
million and he started that I think in
2015 I said most recently in 2023 he had
so he 11 exit so we had 11 million users
and 160 million page views and you could
see how slowly these types of businesses
build and it would be very hard to break
this company down this is they have a
true moat yeah 100% should we help them
with like a marketing slogan maybe dude
this guy this guy's this guy's killing
it man whatever he's doing I want to be
part of it but let me tell you about an
even let me tell you an even crazier
story this actually should be a movie so
there's a website called Bricklink
Bricklink was started in two in the year
so one of the you know early early early
first website businesses first internet
companies so Bricklink it originally
started as brick Bay brick Bay the guy
who started his name is Dan jesic so you
you spelled that last name j zek do me a
favor and type in Dan jnik uh on your on
your uh Chrome and go to his personal
website you see his personal website it
looks like a geoc city uh website is he
dead why is like he dead he's dead okay
so let me tell you this story so Dan
started he Dan was a was he they didn't
explicitly say this but it sort of
sounded like he was a hacker type of guy
and so he was kind of like a a little
bit gray hat where he was the type of
guy who probably like would break into
like different websites and things like
that that's that's the vibe that I got
from him but he was fascinated
fascinated with Legos and so he built
this website called brick Bay it was
called brick Bay at the time because he
lived in Hawaii on a bay eventually he
got sued by eBay they're like you can't
use Bay so we changed it to Brick link
and he was kind of like reading about
him I kind of got Vibes of Ross olrick
the guy who started Silk Road it was one
guy he was Anonymous and he would blog
about all the changes he was making to
the website but it was under the name
admin he never used his real name and it
was just him and he had a handful of
volunteer admins who helped him run the
site and he ran it like a community and
what Bricklink does is you can buy and
sell different types of Legos and so the
thing about Legos is if you build a
thing you don't have any more joy for it
sometimes so you can pack it up in the
boxes and you could sell it uh and just
get a little bit of your money back and
then keep going or buy rare or
interesting pieces and so he ran this
for 10 years and it became a good
business however he died tragically no
one online actually says how he died we
don't know a lot of people suspected a
drug overdose but we don't know but he
was working on this website full-time 24
hours a day seven days a week it was
like a full-time gig when he died his
mother imagine like a cute old lady who
like bakes cookies that's what his mom
looks like and when he died his mom l
you know she loved her son and she was
so passionate about the community that
he made that she was like well I can't
let this community go away and so her
and her husband uh Dan's stepdad took
over the website but because it was just
one guy running it they didn't even have
the passwords they didn't even know how
it was run and so they eventually called
the web hosting site or the web hosting
service and they're like hey here's what
happened can you help us they gave him
the passwords and they just spent three
years figuring this out and trying to
make the community Thrive again it did
and the community stepped up and they're
like we got to do this for Dan this
community is too good we can't let brick
uh brick link go away we love buying and
selling Legos here and so they run this
business for three years and it becomes
a good business now Dan dies they're
running it three years later a
billionaire named Jay Kim bought it have
you ever heard of Jay Kim no so Jay Kim
if you click his Wikipedia obviously J
Jay Kim is not his real name it's uh Jim
Kim Jung Jun Jay Kim was basically kind
of like the Marcus P Mark Pinkus of
Korea so he in the 90s he was early in
the internet and he created games and he
became the biggest gaming company in
Korea then he was a billionaire so he
starts this family holding company where
he buys a bunch of interesting companies
and Bricklink was one of the companies
that he loved another one now this is
where kind of comes into your your world
by the way it says at the time of his
death he was the third wealthiest person
in all of Korea yeah he's a big deal
he's a big deal but J Kim he was like a
steward for this website so they
basically they didn't change much but
one of the reasons why he bought it and
one of the things that makes this
interesting and I'll read this excerpt
from uh from uh basically uh Dan the
original Bricklink owner's mom wrote
this beautiful tribute so if you go to
Dan jes.com wrote this amazing tribute
where they show pictures of Dan and him
growing up and working on Bricklink so
she wrote this amazing thing and I'll
read part of it and she said not long
before he died he developed an
international monetary exchange engine
called Bricklink that allowed sellers
almost anywhere in the world to sell in
their own currency and their customers
could buy in their own currency as well
and every two hours this system that he
that Dan built it would update and so
you can buy cross country and or across
the world and your currency would
automatically be updated and so everyone
was getting a fair shape he built that
in 2010 which is pretty fascinating and
Jay Kim also owns bitstamp have you
heard a bitstamp yeah crypto crypto
exchange right one of the largest crypto
exchanges in the world and so theas why
this guy Dan and this whole story is
fascinating is there's actually some
weird crypto implications here where you
see this overlap of like wow what this
guy Dan was doing is actually like in
the same world of this this whole crypto
thing and he was pretty early to it and
these Lego fans and if you go to uh
Bricklink and see the comments they're
all similar it's all a similar type of
people and this business Bricklink it's
fascinating and oddly Jay Kim also died
under mysterious circum ances in his 50s
in Hawaii where Dan died and so there's
a bunch of like weird things going on
with the story but Bricklink is a very
fascinating company and most recently
Jay Kim after he died Lego the company
bought the website and they openly said
we bought this website because we want
to carry on this tradition we don't want
anyone messing with it we don't intend
to do too much with it we just want to
keep it going because this is for the
people wow that's pretty cool very
fascinating on on this guy's website on
this guy's website it says uh here's a
quote from him about what he wants to do
after he there's a subject there's a
post on the Forum that said was called
afterlife question mark who Jak Kim or
or Dan uh Dan Dan he goes after I die
here and go to heaven this is how I
imagine it to be a place where there's
infinite amount of bricks and an
infinite amount of time to build them
with um to build with them uh there
would be all kinds of bricks for all
themes so that I could get so that when
I got bored of building a castle I could
move on to a town or a pirate ship ship
there would be lots and lots of other
Lego Maniacs to share ideas and build
with isn't that it's right this so great
and if you read this guy Dan if if both
Dan and Nathan from the other website
they use these just like uh what was his
name dread Pirates what what's the Silk
Road guy yeah whatever they they it's a
Marketplace but it's a weird movement
and it's a weird diary and it's like a
cult and there's a very particular
leader and he is leading the charge it's
a really nobody knew his name he was
just called admin on he was just ad no
one they kind of knew it was Dan but he
never like revealed his name and it was
just oh admin's doing this and it's just
this weird like it all stems from like
you know remember like the phone freaks
like people who would like hack into um
uh pay phones and then there was uh the
internet and they were doing things like
that now there's crypto like it's this
weird chain where it's actually all
quite similar it's this weird
underground community and so as a
business person I see these I see these
things and I'm like what other products
cost a lot of money have a passionate
nerdy following and where you can build
a large audience and then eventually
sell them ev Everything and Lego fits
that perfectly I think there's a few
others you've named a few but it's it
was actually challenging for me to find
other things that were at like this but
like sneaker heads are kind of one of
them but there's it's just really
fascinating how how big I think these
businesses can be even though they
appear quite Niche oh dude I I forgot
Thrill of the shill so first of all the
thrill of the shill is one of the chef's
kiss best inventions we've had uh and
unlike the gentleman's agreement which
we kind of stole from somebody else the
throw the shill is actually an original
but I have a different thing I want to
try today are you down for it yes the
throw of the show by the way came up
literally 30 seconds before we hit
record a few weeks ago and we said how
do we promote interesting stuff and you
were like well we got to tell them
valuable content and then hopefully
they'll buy whatever we're selling just
call it the throw of the show so
congratulations let's hear it yeah so
that so that was good but now I want to
try something different have you ever
read this thing that is um like this the
famous Hemingway story I'm sure you have
because you're a copywriter guy which is
the six-word story do you know this
about the guy outside holding the the
poster board like the baker uh I don't
know if it's that exactly but basically
there was a challenge which was tell it
was a six-word story contest so it was
how do you tell a story in six only you
only have six words and the the the lore
is that they told us to Ernest Hemingway
and he came up with the six word story
and he won um which was for sale baby
shoes never worn six words tells a tells
a deep story hits you in the emotions
there's another story like that where
there's a homeless guy sitting outside
and he says uh like I'm blind please
help and a a famous copywriter writes he
goes let me help you and he goes uh it's
spring outside or it's springtime and
then I'm blind please help and so I have
a six-word challenge six-word Thrill of
the shill that I'm I'm gonna hit you
with all right so I'm going to do my
Heming way I'm going to do this whole ad
in six words here we go business for
sale owner never
hired and it's about this business it's
a story about a business that failed and
it's up for sale now and then why
because the owner never hired he tried
to do it all himself and he just never
made the key hires that he needed to
scale the business because he didn't go
to support shepard.com and find amazing
talent overseas to hire at a low cost
five times less than the United States
boom how was my story that was beautiful
that was dude the Hemingway one was
quite good too that I'm still thinking
about that one what is it uh business I
shouldn't have put Heming way before my
one that I made up one minute ago maybe
I should have done the alltime best
against mine what was it what was the
line uh business for sale owner never
hired bu for sale just like the shoes
for sale business for sale owner never
hired I thought it was good support
shepard.com that's the that's the shill
the thrill was a beautiful line there we
go back to the episode you know the
other one that's most like this is
fanfiction so watpad reminds me a lot of
this where whatpad and there's also
another one that's like uh some Wiki
it's like a Wiki it's like a Wikipedia
But fandom fan uh yeah I think Phantom
like bought them or something like that
but there's another one that's just
straight the Wikipedia part of it um but
fanfiction so people get super super
super passionate about Harry Potter and
about you know different um books and
then kind of spin out their own their
own world right like uh I remember
mugglenet which was started by that guy
Emerson sparts and uh you know or spats
I don't know I don't know how you say
his last name um they built such a huge
huge website just around fans of Harry
Potter it was very much like you know
brick link or whatever and on that I
remember I used to go on there and read
people because we'd be waiting for the
last book to come out and people would
write their own versions of that last
book and uh they would you know you
would just read like a full length book
that somebody just wrote in their spare
time for fun and that led to some big
things like you know 50 Shades of Gray
came out of a fanfiction post uh just
like that like it was written originally
as a fanfiction post around Twilight and
so fanfiction and if you people who were
surprised that Wattpad was giving like
hundreds of millions of visitors every
month like one of the most popular
websites in the world I think they sold
for $ 600 million dollar to a Korean
company recently two years ago maybe
yeah and they weren't making any money
but they weren't making much money but
but the the passion and the the usage
was there it was off the charts and then
you know you don't have to do it much
marketing because the people who are
passionate about it are going to search
the internet for every nook and cranny
to find you know other people like who
are as fanatical about it as them so
there's a few attributes here that I I
I'm just thinking about at the top of my
head so attribute number one is they
seem like jokes at first so like it's
kind of silly like almost embarrassing
like what do you do for a living oh I
run a Lego blog like it seems silly when
you talk about it
uh at first but if there's enough people
it's it could be pretty great the second
thing is I actually think I think these
types of companies you shouldn't build
quickly these are slow bird businesses
where you don't want to get too big too
fast otherwise the Nerds the passionate
ones will be like oh this is lame this
is too big too mainstream getting
commercial yeah but number three is if
you do it right they have huge Moes and
they're very very hard to kill get very
loyal to them but just like actually New
York Times cooking actually had this a
few years ago so New York Times cooking
is a similar Community like this
passionate fans they had a Revolt
because uh in their Facebook group
someone made a change an admin made a
change and they revolted I don't know if
you remember this about two or three
years ago uh they had 60,000 people in
the New York Times cooking they changed
something where like you had to get your
post approved as opposed to posting on
your own a change like that people
revolted and so these communities you're
basically a steward of the people you're
not you're not you're not all the time a
dictator you have to be very you have
your your fans are temperamental um and
so there's pros and cons to these types
of companies but I do think they are
very very valuable because of how hard
they can be to
ruin the um do you think not to be
self-serving but just real real
discussion do you think we can kind of
do this I I kind of think that we have
the makings of doing something like this
but we also might eff It Up by trying to
yes grow it too fast so for example one
of the best tests I I remember talking
to Ben once and uh one of the best tests
for will somebody like MFM is this
experience do you ever go to a
restaurant and then you can't help it
but your brain is like trying to
calculate the like how much is this
restaurant making like you basically
start counting the tables and then you
count you know you you just count the
tables you figure oh this many meals per
hour what's our bill our bill is this
much okay average ticket is this and you
end up with like what's the E of this
restaurant and that if you're like that
you're probably going to like this
podcast it's a very high like you know
overlap but being like that is weird
right that's not a normal way that
people are most people just go to the
restaurant they look at the menu they
order the food and if you're sitting
down with four other people no one elide
that table is going to nerd out with you
like look how packed this place is like
wow how much you think one of these
servers is per hour and look how much
the meal like you know what I mean no
one you're gonna dork out with that but
no one be like dude shut the [__] up and
just eat your chicken parm exactly and
so in the same way that most of the Lego
people if they went to school could not
find somebody as or they go to in this
adult one you go to work you're not
going to find people who are trying to
build the this 2000piece Chinese
restaurant that they bought the
blueprint for for $10 like you're not
going to find your people there and so
you find your people elsewhere you find
it on brick Bricklink you find it on
rebrickable or whatever um I think for
us uh it's the same thing that person
who's at that dinner the six people
they're at the dinner with your you
family your friends they might not want
to dork out about it but you find us and
the community of people that like this
and you're like these are all people who
want to know the Eid of the restaurant
and so it becomes this like glue and you
find your people and I think I've been
tempted in the past to try to grow this
faster and the things you do to grow it
faster are sort of like dilutive you
actually sell out a little you sell out
a little right like it's the cringey
YouTube thumbnail face it's the um you
know it's the talking about a topic that
might not be the thing you would
actually want to dork out about like I
like that this episode is basically 90%
us Dorking out about these like Niche
LEGO websites versus things that might
be more mainstream you know talking
about the Super bowl next week or
whatever but it will attract the right
people I I thought the Super Bowl was in
November I didn't even know
that I that's news to
me so uh okay that's one thing the
second is like a business principle I
saw so somebody said this that I thought
was really good they go if you want to
build like a a truly a truly strong
business build like a reverse funnel I
was like oh that's interesting so like I
always think of every business as a
funnel but I always think about it from
top to bottom what do you mean audience
first yeah top of the funnel is people
who don't know you they they they come
to your website for the first time they
hear your podcast for the first time
they hear about your product for the
first time and that's like you know they
become aware of you and then they might
get interested then they might actually
sign up as a user then they might sign
up for the paid account and the paid
account is always at the bottom and I
always just thought of a funnel as top
to bottom and with this person was
saying was they go yeah you actually
want the reverse you want to build as a
reverse funnel meaning you want to find
like the 10 people who are most
interested and passionate about what
you're doing to where you know you these
are your extreme hardcore users who
absolutely love that you're doing this
and they will use it every day and give
you feedback and they'll annoy you with
their feedback they'll tell all their
friends their friends won't even listen
it doesn't matter and they're your power
power users and then you sort of go one
rung up and you go to like the next
hundred people who care a lot for sure
but less than those 10 who are like
really nuts and you go to thousand
people 10,000 people 100 thousand and
you you stack the funnel from the
bottoms up is a way to think about
building an enduring product because
you're really going to find the people
who need it the most who love it the
most they're going to give you the best
feedback to give you to get the product
to be uh you know better and you're
going to find you know the people who
love it versus everybody else who's kind
of like oh that's cool um and and I
thought oh that's actually a good
principle too when it comes to how to
build something I don't know when you
built Hampton did you did you do that
yeah for sure yes how did you think
about who the first let's say 10 to 20
people should be how did you decide that
so at first I was like let me figure out
who wants this most but then I uh I and
I had ideas as to who that would be and
what I found was I was like wow there's
a lot of entrepreneurs in Tennessee Iowa
Idaho Delaware some of these forgotten
areas that aren't on the coast and I'm
shocked at how lonely they are and how
much they need this let's go get more of
those people and so that's what we did
is I didn't I thought it was going to be
like cool new York or San Francisco
people and turns out it was cool
Kentucky guys too but like I just didn't
even they weren't even part of my like
they weren't even part of my vernacular
I wouldn't even have thought about them
and so that's what we did I think um
with this podcast I think it's good that
you and I have other businesses that a
pay us money and B can grow faster
because there's been very there's been
it's been very tempting to try to do
things that are inauthentic but we know
they will get more views and actually
we've done a good job of sticking to
like being authentic but this is the
this is a very that was a really good
point of yours that this podcast as well
as the handful of other ones there are
like these nerdy things that a small
group of people are really passionate
about like for example did you see the
meetups that people were doing for MFM I
was just about to bring that up that's
an example the test dude do you know
they're still meeting like they're
they're still meeting that's exactly
right so we thought I guess uh the first
mind-blowing thing was oh if me and Sam
say we're going to go to some place to
do a live show wow we could fill like
you know a thousand to 2,000 people in a
in a whatever a theater to to come watch
us and it's a ton of work what's that
it's a ton of work we were both just
like all right let's not really do this
a pressure and and you know we cool we
had the moment where it was felt good
but like I don't know if that's what we
want to do on an ongoing basis and then
somebody came to us forget her name off
top my head Rachel Rachel river river
and she's like hey our product does this
she's like yeah our product is for
creators who have a community let your
community meet up without you and I was
like key word without you love it um and
I was like actually that kind of makes
sense because again it you know while it
feels good to maybe be like you know the
center of attention doesn't really feel
good and also that's not actually what
makes something really valuable but what
we'd rather do is use our content as a
magnet as a Honeypot to bring in the
cool guy from Kentucky and the cool girl
from Illinois who they all do the
restaurant thing where they start
calculating restaurant revenues when
when they walk into a restaurant and get
them together because they're going to
hit it off but it'd be hard for them to
find each other and so if all we serve
as is basically the finding function for
those people to meet and what's cool is
that they did the first Meetup but then
now they've just been meeting on a
monthly basis that tells me that we did
something right I don't know we didn't
intend to do that to be very clear like
that was not none of this was
intentional but that that means
something went right I facetimed a few
of them like they was like Hey we're
doing this thing I was like all right
cool I'll FaceTime and just say hi and
there was people and by the way we we
have like there's no like monetary thing
I think it's completely free if you
Google MFM and then River Meetup you'll
see like the landing page I talked to
people they were like yeah I drove six
hours to come to this one because I'm
looking for a husband or a wife like I
want to meet someone who has these
similar values that for some reason MFM
is a proxy for uh and so I thought that
was like super fascinating and they told
me they go oh we're still actually doing
monthly meetings because we just want to
hang out with other dorks like us and I
thought that was awesome by the way our
our what my tagline for people that will
like this is just business business
nerds with a sense of humor that's the
whole thing if you're a business nerd
like meaning like you do business but
you also in addition to the business you
run you actually kind of nerd out about
more business stuff you can't can't
really get enough it doesn't feel like
work to you to think about business or
to read about businesses or learn more
business stuff and then with a sense of
humor because there's probably people
that are you know more experienced than
us that share more tactical stuff that
are um you know whatever they're smart
or better they're more to the point but
I think the one thing we do is we try to
we have a lot of fun while we do this
and that rubs off and so that's the the
capture of like who is the audience for
us so we just dorked out on like Niche
Niche passionate things I think that um
this Lego [__] is crazy fascinating um
you'll have to go to the Dan jic site
Dan jes.com just to look at this and
maybe you guys will dork out over uh
over this like I did and by the way if
you made it this far into the Pod you're
definitely one of these nerds just go
ahead this is my one sellout go ahead
and click subscribe on the YouTube page
because you made it this far and you can
actually make fun of us in the comments
or let us know what you think about this
Niche stuff I have one more quick one
that's like kind of in the theme of kid
stuff games toys have you seen the thing
called pal world I know you're not a
gamer but do do you know about this no
what is pal World pal world is currently
like the most popular PC game in the
world and it came out of nowhere tell me
what steam I still don't I don't
understand exactly what steam is steam
is like an app store but for computers
the company that makes Counterstrike
they in order to let people come
download the new version of
Counterstrike and buy it they created
steam it's like a store to sell counter
you know sell Counterstrike but it also
sold all the other games right so now
anybody can list their thing there but I
can't do it on Apple well no because
you're playing on a you know a razor PC
or something like that so what do you
need to the Apple App Store for right
that's not going to work um so it's the
Apple App Store but for computer games
um and huge by the way like
multi-billion dollar product so the
number one game on Steam right now is
pal World pal World in like like seven
days has done 200 million in Revenue
when games hit they hit like none other
and by the way this thing was made like
on a $10,000 budget so it was like a
very very lowcost game what's
interesting about this right so the game
is basically uh the game to me the
reason I wanted to bring this up not
because I I I'm not even playing the
game it's not like you play games so we
don't have a lot to talk about here but
I do think it's an example of the midwit
meme strikes again and this is basically
that the best ideas the absolute best
ideas are simple and they're not just
simple they're simple to the point of
sounding
dumb okay so simple to the point of
sounding dumb what does that mean so uh
to me this is uh let's see simple to the
point of sounding dumb is Snapchat the
next big social app it wasn't started as
this like Grand intellectual theory on
the future of of communication it was
like What if you could send someone a
picture that would like disappear in 10
seconds nudes College nudes right and
people are like what would you do with
that I don't know stupid [__] why stupid
[__] because it's going to disappear in
10 seconds so I have no no filter right
and then after the fact it becomes this
thing that people intellectualize and
they're like well see the thing is that
um you know impermanence is actually the
greatest form of permanence like what
what are you talking about and uh and
people start to get intellectual about
it but that's not where the best ideas
come from the best ideas come from
really really simple things that can be
described in just a couple words words
pal world if you go look at this game
what's the game the game is Pokemon with
guns it's like what it's like yes and
then literally the CEO he he says this
he goes I'm not a Visionary I I don't
know how to do that um I just try to
make whatever people want and I knew
that uh Pokemon yeah he didn't say
Pokemon because he doesn't want to get
sued but he's like yeah I had this idea
of like you know you could run around
and capture these little monsters but
then we added guns because you know
Americans love to shoot things that's
insane that was like the the core idea
and he was like they're like so why you
know what was the decision to do this
art style he's like oh I didn't even
want to do that actually I wanted to do
like cool 3D thing but I didn't even
know that to do that you have to have
like an animation rig and all this stuff
he's like so I made one and I was like
God that was hard I there's no way we
could do this with like 10,000
characters like impossible um he's like
so we had this artist that we had
rejected and then we like hired her
later and they're like oh oh they're
like what you know what did you tell her
to do she like I don't know like
whatever our programmer could make like
that was her mandate they're like what
was your budget he's like I don't know
we had like $10,000 but um we didn't
really set a budget he's like you know I
guess if we needed more I would have
probably just gone and borrowed some
more they're like tell us about the
developers on your team he's like one of
my developers is a guy I met like at a
convenience store this kid he's like a
teenager but like he told me he could
code so I told him to come by and you
know he works on the game he's pretty
critical for the game so the founder has
written this like really amazing blog
post where he like explains everything
that you're talking about and he's like
he's kind of he's like a [__] in the
best possible way and he's like he
basically says he goes this game
shouldn't even exist uh it's the inis of
proper game development and he says um
he goes we had no budget uh No Sa
company would ever start developing a
game without a budget but pocket pair
which is the developer is not a sane
company and he just talks about so I
started asking myself what's the budget
when the balance of our bank account
reached zero we could always just borrow
money or release money just before the
company went bankrupt we had about two
years to Runway and I decided just to
keep working without stressing about
budget because all I was worried about
was getting the game done as fast as
possible and he's like quite not like a
corporate Ste CEO this is like pretty
awesome he's in Japan is this a Japanese
guy uh yeah it's a Japanese game he
basically made some money in crypto and
then took the crypto money and was like
all right I'm gonna start a game studio
with this even though he kind of wasn't
like you know equipped to do that um
like right now on Steam it's the number
one game that right now as we're
recording this there're was over 1
million people concurrently playing the
game right now in this second um like
the highest was two million at a time
were playing the game just concurrently
it's the number one more than DOTA more
than Counter Strike more than pubg more
than all of them he was like uh this one
lady applied but I didn't think her
designs were that good so I rejected her
but then she kept three months later she
sent me a DM DM and I was so amazed that
she was bold enough after I rejected her
to keep messaging me so we hired her uh
like like he just has like story after
Story of like that doesn't make sense so
let's do it uh but the meme the mid meme
where it's like you know the idiot and
the Jedi kind of think the same thing
right like just like just make the game
as fast as possible right or like you
know if you're run out of money just try
to get some more um you
know what should you make it what if
Pokemon had guns that' be cool right
it's like versus people who are like you
know trying to over overly
intellectualize and overanalyze
everything and um I just see this trend
over over and over and over again I I
truly believe did I tell you about the
midwit thing I'm trying to do no what I
truly believe this midwit meme explains
so much of my own life and like I want
to see it every day as a reminder to
don't overthink it just keep it simple
and just what's the obvious answer
what's the obvious answer is like it's
always there but it gets fogged up by my
own stupidity trying to overly over
architect things or like want to be an
intellectual and so George Mack our
friend you you know George he's awesome
yeah he's a great dude very interesting
thinker and so he had this idea for a
like to do a super glossy like coffee
table book high-end but of just like 100
midwit memes and I heard this idea and I
was like that's genius I can't wait and
so I messaged him and then like months
later I was like dude what happened to
the book and he's like oh well I didn't
want to do it because you know um you
know I was gonna have to do 365 his
original thing was 365 like one a day
365 midwit memes he's like I didn't know
I get to 365 and I thought well the you
know the cost of this might be a little
high I'm not sure if I'm going to be
able to make my money back but then you
know he's like really a bestselling book
is something that has these attributes
and I went and studied all the
bestselling books and I I learned all
these commonalities between atomic
habits and this and this and this and I
just sent him the midw beam back after
his like thousand-word like what'sapp
message and I was like make the book
it'll be fun right like that's obvious
like just make the just do it it'll be
fun who cares like you don't have to do
all these things it might lose a little
bit of money it's okay right like the
people who bu something cool will come
with this it's it's no big deal and so
I'm trying to convince him to do this uh
to do this book with me I'm like let's
just make this book it'll take us like
two weeks and it'll be fun and like
anybody who actually buys this thing is
going to be the exact type of person I
want in my life just do it do it on your
own I'm looking for an excuse to do a
project with George because I really
like him and also this was his idea so I
don't want to steal his idea I want to
convince him to do this with me if he if
he really refuses I'm gonna say all
right can I just do this myself and
myself it's Monday day I think this
episode goes live on Wednesday I forget
when but whenever it goes live give him
he has seven days if this doesn't get to
do tweet at georgem his uh his his
Twitter handle
George just tweet at him at just say do
it and he he he's gonna have to figure
out why everybody's tweeting do it at
him and I'm sure he will eventually put
two two together and know this is what
I'm this is why he needs to do it I uh I
enjoyed this episode what do you think
yeah this is fun I enjoy Dorking out
over this stuff I had a great time do we
wrap here is that the pod that's the Pod
I feel like I learned something today
yeah and I had a great time that's the
mid that's the midwit meme of preparing
for these things I'm like uh what gets
views what what uh what will what will
make more money and what will be more
fun um all right that's the
[Music]
pod